Hello Freak bitches.
I've been watching some pro wrestling.
Totally predicted what was going to happen with this John [inaudible] Brock
Lesnar.
Oh yeah.
You knew the thing out about it.
Bronc Lesnar,
you played it out long in advance perfectly.
You knew exactly how it was going to go down.
And you're saying that it sets up something in the future?
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
They offered me a full time writing job.
I can talk about it now cause I'm not getting it.
I'm not doing it.
But a couple months ago they offered me a full time job to move to Stamford,
Connecticut.
Yeah.
After one meeting,
a meeting like this,
that was about an hour and a half at the end they go,
how would you feel about moving to Stamford,
Connecticut for one year job with the WWE writing hung the creative side.
And I go,
I'm going to have to think about that.
And uh,
it didn't pan out because I didn't want to move to Stanford,
Connecticut and working nine to five,
even though it's really good money and everything.
But you would have to go to,
you drive to a la or drive to New York rather still do spots,
which turns out it's just a 45 minute drive.
But,
but the job is very grueling.
The WWE thing,
it's not a,
it's not like TV comedy writing job.
It's like a,
I'd have to answer to Vince Mcmahon like Tony,
would you do get stoned before writing this ideal?
Do you think that's what it was?
Or probably what would you say to him?
Well,
if you want to say,
I say yeah and I was still,
when I wrote all the great ideas that you like sir.
Well you have a point.
I think Vince,
we tried to get you on steroids.
Um,
he'd probably get,
yeah,
we tried to get me to eat.
Be every chance he gets.
He brought it from my ranch.
Shot this myself this morning.
Yeah.
Well was it good money?
Like serious money.
Super serious money.
Wow.
Sanely serious money.
You came close.
I was happy to get the offer.
I took it as a victory and I love what I do.
I love what I'm doing.
And it might be crazy.
I'll never regret it.
You know what I mean?
I think you regret it right now.
I'm looking into your eyes.
So yeah.
No,
it's kind of a dream job for you.
Yeah,
sort of.
But then again,
what I do is sort of a dream job too,
and giving up this dream job for that dream job would be crazy.
You wouldn't have to give up this dream job.
I'm telling you,
it's a grueling,
creepy job,
unfortunately.
Trust me,
if it was,
if,
if the word on the streets was man writing for the WWE,
it's the coolest.
You can do anything.
I would have taken it and I would have lived in New York and it would have been
amazing.
I would have traveled to Stanford 45 minutes every morning on a subway and
steadily Dunnigan Stanford.
Yeah.
It would have been amazing.
And I would have had any,
I could have.
It was stupid.
The amount of money.
You don't want to live in Stanford.
You know what the problem with Connecticut is?
It's not really a state is a state.
But let's be honest,
ladies and gentlemen,
you,
you live in a highway between Boston and New York.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's like they put some houses on the side of the highway and they call it a
town,
but that's what's really going on.
There's nothing,
nothing's being done there and nuns be made there.
What do you got?
You've got the Glenn Beck and the WWE.
That's your entire state economy.
Yeah,
of course.
There's some other things I'm just fucking around.
Don't get,
don't get all fucking,
I'll stanfordy on me.
Don't get all attached and proud of Connecticut,
Connecticut pride.
We got a fucking email.
Joe Connecticut Pride.
Connecticut sucks.
You know,
it sucks and I know it sucks.
There's some great houses there.
Some nice neighborhoods,
crazy neighbor.
I have my friend Tommy Junior,
one of my best friends lives in Connecticut.
He tells me it sucks.
I trust him.
It's not a good spot.
When I used to drive there from Boston to New York,
I would always think like,
why is,
why aren't people stop in here?
Yeah,
WWE.
But a lot of people,
like David Letterman lived in Connecticut and drove into the city to do a show.
That's how he did it.
Yeah.
But he's like reclusive,
you know?
Hmm.
He likes being,
he needs to be away from everybody.
He's weird like that.
And you're not.
You missed her outgoing and that city partying it up at night,
doing a little blow in the morning,
pep you up right before class.
Uh,
for sure.
You know me show up on the campus.
Give Vince the paperwork that you wrote on the plane over there
toady.
This storyline makes zero sense.
What kind of story lines where you plan it?
Did you,
I know you did.
I know you thought about it.
Absolutely.
I wrote a,
I wrote a great storyline where,
you know,
Brock Lesnar and a,
in this past Wrestlemania,
he'd beat the undertaker.
The undertaker's had a streak at Wrestlemania.
He never loses at Wrestlemania.
He was 21 and zero all time at Wrestlemania 21 years.
He had never lost in this match against Brock Lesnar.
It's sort of,
it was sort of set up so everybody just assumed the undertaker would win and
then in a stunning move,
Brock,
towards the end of it ends up beating the undertaker for the three counts.
You want to see something funny?
Look that up.
Reaction shots of the audience.
Don't do that.
Okay,
but this audience was stunned to people.
Just so I know.
What else jogs drawn that audience.
A fucking simple card trick.
Oh,
come on.
What are you talking about?
Listen to code road.
Silly Shit.
Okay.
It's all planned out.
It's obvious.
It's not obvious.
It's definitely not.
If it's planned out,
why would it be obvious going to happen?
I know what's going to happen.
That's,
you know,
that's not the,
that's not the arena's.
Not everybody in the arena was offered a full time,
one year writing job with the,
they don't know what's going to happen.
You're an expert in pro wrestling essentially.
I've watched my whole,
it was sorta like my replacement for not having a dad when I was a kid.
Like,
I would just sit there and watch these,
these storylines and these guys do all this crazy stuff.
Well,
it was my dad replaced
superfly snuck.
Was Your Dad pretty much?
Super Fly was one of the biggest things.
I mean,
that's what I was doing off of couches and my tidy whities when I was a tiny
little boy,
Bob Backlund.
I remember Bob Backlund,
the creator of the cross face chicken wing,
which is a great move,
man.
Much fucking time.
You invest in this.
You should get paid by this.
Seriously considered seriously consider taking that job.
Uh,
no.
I would say no to anybody else,
but you,
you like that shit so much.
You've always got those fucking books.
He read books on the business of pro wrestling.
We're on a fucking plane and I look over,
there's people reading his self help books.
Some folks are reading novels.
Tony H is going to fucking book the sex and politics lies in headlocks the
unauthorized bio of Vince Mcmahon.
What the fuck are you doing?
Reading awesomeness about a guy who took a joke of a show and turn it into a
billion dollar enterprise and wrote it all himself and is the main,
you should read her book on pro wrestling.
Dude,
you should write a book,
a love affair,
pro wrestling.
I love affair from Tony Hinchcliffe.
I was listening to,
um,
to watch the opening Anthony Show,
which is no longer the opn Anthony show.
Now it's a ob with Jimmy Norton.
I Dunno,
why don't they just call it the opion Jimmy show,
but whatever.
Um,
they had this guy on and uh,
he's an author.
He's,
he wrote that card movie with Kevin Spacey.
He's written a bunch of 'em,
a bunch of different,
uh,
books.
His name is Ben Massell,
rich man's rich.
And he was talking about Russian oligarchy and about what happened,
what went down and Russia during like the fall of the Soviet Union were seven to
nine people,
but soaked up 50% of the economy of Russia.
Yeah.
Seven,
seven or nine,
somewhere in that number.
Like,
no more than 10 people literally had 50% of the Russian economy.
And they were just killing each other.
They would like kill each other and take over their businesses.
Like if you had a competitor,
if like you were coke,
you would send your army over to kill Pepsi and then you would just own Pepsi to
wow.
It's,
it was the total complete wild,
wild west.
And I don't know if he's written a book on this or he's gonna write a book on
this,
but fucking a man listen to that shit.
Whiskey.
I bet he has written a book on it.
I should find out what the book is been as rich Ben Mezrich I wonder what the
direction of the economy and the trends and everything were before that
exclusive group of people took that over.
Cause it's,
you know,
it seems like we're sort of in a way,
heading that direction with our stuff.
The top whatever percent has such a crazy amount of money compared to the rest
of everybody.
Yeah.
Well it's close.
You know,
were,
were pretty bad.
But uh,
apparently it's nothing like Russia,
like the,
these Russian oligarchs,
they just dominated.
They just figured out a way to completely dominate the entire economy of a giant
country.
I mean it's,
it's listening to him talk about,
it was fascinating.
That shows different now that Anthony's not there,
but Jimmy Norton is so fucking interesting.
Hysterical.
And you know,
an obese doing a great job with it too.
It's still a great show.
This Guy Ben Mezrich was fascinating.
Fuck Russia man.
It's crazy.
They were talking about Putin,
but what a gangster Putin had to be to,
to come back and lead the country after he left.
Like he led the country,
took off like the,
the impose some sort of a term limit came back like no term limit in buck.
Oh,
he's back again.
Like he's,
this is a second time running the country.
Like he installed some sort of a puppet dictator or a puppet leader when he was
gone and then came back and he's a former KGB agent.
Like what the fuck man.
You know,
there's a guy that a,
a professional wrestler named Marie Seth that actually puts the Cutin on the,
on the mega tron and the,
and Tron.
Uh,
every time he comes out and really gets the crowd riled up.
Oh mother Russia,
I promise I will defeat my victim for you.
And it gets the whole crowd to hate him.
And then I,
and then a guy comes out and uh,
he Rousseff usually wins.
They let the Russian guy when cause it drives the crowd crazy and then you think
anything can happen after that.
Fuck.
My favorite thing is to watch you respond to me.
Talk about rats.
What's wrong with you?
You would love it around with you.
I wouldn't love it.
You'd be amazed.
I'll bet you though.
I bet you if I showed you a statistic of UFC fans being WWE fans,
I bet you'd be shocked because before the UFC was all over everything and one of
the only outlets that end,
by the way,
I've been with the UFC since the beginning,
you know what I mean?
Like I mean like watching it,
it's since the hoists days since voice and shamrock and all that.
And that's because it's it.
Even though it's two totally different things.
UFC is obviously an extremely,
you know,
crazy sport and WWE is completely entertainment with,
some injuries from time to time.
Uh,
you know,
the,
it was an outlet for anybody that wanted some crazy stuff.
Wwe and UFC fans.
I bet there's a lot.
I would bet you that you're done talking.
This is it.
This is my,
this is my closing statement.
Here it is.
I'll bet you that at least 70% of UFC fans have been or are a WWE fan at some
point 70%.
I love when people throw a statistic around where they have done zero research,
just a random number.
I believe 70.
I do it all the time,
by the way.
Uh,
I'm 70 and I bet 90% of no I did.
They look,
it's not the God damn same.
One of them is real.
One of them people that are battling for their life and the most difficult
contest and all of sports.
Another one is weird fucking jerk off thing that strange guys do when they sit
in front of the TV and pretend they don't know it's fake.
Right.
10 payment.
No,
I know it's fake.
Everybody knows it's fake.
You don't want to know.
You shut that part of your brain off when you watch it.
You like like a lizard.
They told me to take a full time writers job.
I know it's fake.
Even even if you wrote it,
you would still be there while it happened.
I can't believe
he wrote his safety order taker.
You would hope you would have your fucking script in your hand and you'd be
jumping up and down,
spinning around in circles.
I can't believe prompt the undertaker.
Oh yeah.
I'm real and Grabow worlds Calamari.
He never got to finish.
So I wrote a thing to where Cain,
the undertakers brother wrestled Brock Lesnar at this wrestlemania coming up in
seven months or so and uh,
loses but undertaker comes back.
Tombstone pal drives Brock Lesnar and they walk off together.
Amazing Swan Song.
They wake up.
Right.
Well,
when you come up with a move for a guy to win with,
yeah.
Do you take into consideration at all the health of the person tried to attempt
that move?
It's tough.
You're right.
Yeah.
It's tough because when Brock Lesnar did that shooting star press flipped
through the air and landed on his head.
I've seen that.
Yeah,
Everybody see anybody like who knew about Brock Lesnar who was researching him.
Very likely if you were going through like internet videos and stuff like that,
you would run into that video of him flipping off the top rope and landing on
his head off 300 pounds of them landed on his head bang and kept going.
Yeah.
Crazy.
I don't know how the fuck he lived.
I know if you watched that,
it looks like he's a dead man.
Yeah,
Wayne's on his fucking head.
Yeah.
There's some stuff that just can't even,
they just probably an inch either way and he's,
he can't move his legs and stuff,
but he survived it.
Walk in music is so powerful because you could psych out an opponent with
walking music if it's done properly.
If it's some,
if it's some subtle crazy stuff,
you know?
No,
you can't.
Little bit.
He can wrestling.
You look around what is trembling?
He's playing that.
Who's that?
Phil Collins.
I can feel it in here.
You think?
I believe this is my song.
I think if you're on,
if you're fighting in the UFC and you come out first,
you add your song.
Let's say your songs like a seven on a one to 10 and then lights go out and Phil
Collins in the air tonight does come in.
You're not a little bit like,
fuck,
I wish I would've picked this guy.
He's already got,
he's already got one on me.
It's already willing to one below,
and that's the intro
you
need to call McMahon right now.
You think like a fucking pro wrestling fan.
And I say that with all due respect,
I'm not,
I'm not hating on it.
But you think like you,
you take the joy moment in that stupidity.
It's entertaining as hell.
Vince,
why are you slipping?
This is the management.
Turn your organization around your them and they should call you the mastermind
and they should make you a character as well.
I agree with you.
Where those gold wrestling shoes,
that's your whole outfit.
It's shiny gold and the mastermind.
Good to be here in Vancouver.
Oh,
what's wrong?
You don't like my plans for the future?
I can feed it.
What is it about all that stuff?
Even though you know it's total 100% horseshit.
What is it about that stuff that's appealing to you?
The Entertainment Gel.
If you watched one of these things,
you would,
you would see what you liked about it and you would have a few favorites and no,
no,
I'll go fucking crazy.
And I'd watched lions killing gazelles on television because that's real.
That's what I'd do.
I'd grab my laptop and I'd be like,
yeah,
you watch this fake shit all day.
I need real.
I can't get entertained by frank.
But that's what TV shows and movies are there.
Fake.
No,
no,
they're not.
Fake sports are real.
And that I understand,
and this is sports entertainment.
It's not,
it's not.
We're not.
Nobody's saying it's really when you watch game of Thrones and you watch a guy
gets his head cut off,
you know what it looks like.
Yeah.
It looks like a guy actually getting his head cut off.
It looks real.
When I watch wrestling and I see a guy get hit and go
turn to the crowd.
I know that's bullshit.
It's offensive to me.
It's offensive.
Yeah.
And the idea is other moves that happen that are amazing.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
They're all offensive.
Oh No.
I know they take athleticism to pull off,
but they're offensive because I'm so aware.
It's so in my face and this is not really happening.
I can't be the guy in the gold suit holding onto the script,
jumping around and place going or lost.
The streak has been broken.
That's what you would do.
You would freak the fuck out.
I would run around.
I wouldn't do that.
You would if you were hired.
If I had a gold suit I would do that,
but I don't have a cold.
I can see you doing it.
Vince is fucking up.
Really needs to make you a part of it.
I told him Tony when immediately you should do it and I can't believe you didn't
take it Tony,
cause that is the way,
one of the biggest things for you,
for you because you are that is trying to negotiate.
Doing it part time from La.
That would be awesome.
That way that would be best for both sides because I wouldn't get burned out on
it and they would have awesome,
great ideas that are hip and cool and I would have been able to do what I wanted
it to happen.
Cool.
Whenever guys says my ideas are hip and cool,
I'll go.
Are you sure?
The pins,
what ideas?
Talking about as a scarf
scarf.
It's a scarf with little skulls all over it.
Like he's a pirate and he's drinking a Frappaccino.
Aren't you ever saw this one coming?
Yes.
Undertaker has gone.
Metro,
Metro sexual undertaker.
Maybe if you changed,
all of a sudden Tony starts working for them and every character becomes a gay
as,
and it turns out that there's,
there's someone who's sprinkling gay dust overall.
The other competitors where there's a locker room and he's turning.
That's the,
that's a plot that Tony comes up when he turns the entire roster gay.
It turns out there's an openly gay wrestler and he has gay fairy dust.
Okay,
well he was,
he didn't like a leprechauns ball sack.
You read,
killed the Leprechaun and turned his ball sack until like this.
Are you ready for this?
What if I were to tell you that there is an openly gay wrestler that blows dust
in people's space?
Fuck out.
His name is gold dust.
No fucking way.
Area is right there.
This is real.
Yeah Dude,
this is in the WWE.
Dustin Rhodes,
a third generation rest.
What's what's going on with his Dick?
That's gold dust.
You've heard of horsepower that's like related to the dusty roads.
Yeah.
Hey,
how'd you know about that city road used to be eight when this shit made sense.
Thank you Joe.
This guy's real.
Please.
I need to see more.
I can't believe I invented a guy that already exist.
Yeah you can.
You should be writing this.
That's him and his,
uh,
insurance cell phone when he takes off the wagon robe and he
flirts with them in the ring and Shit blows and kisses and they get all of
roundup and then he can beat him with shit cause they,
they're like all day.
Get away from me and he's like,
oh yeah,
come here.
Beautiful.
And they're
did the WWE should hire Michael Sam as soon as he's done with the Dallas
cowboys.
The openly gay NFL player.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know.
He's not good enough to make the team and just bringing them for the practice
squad.
They need to bring that dude into WWE and actually fuck a guy on TV.
Well him and gold dust.
Yeah,
but gold does is fake it.
I could tell.
Look it up.
My Guy Straight.
Yeah,
he's super straight.
It's super straight.
I,
you know,
part of me says,
yeah,
zoo animal cruelty of the,
the biggest part,
like in my gut reaction,
I look at that.
Should that be illegal?
Wow.
It wasn't,
oh,
that's kind of a fucked up thing to do.
It's kind of a fucked up thing to put razor blades in the end of a chicken's
foot.
Stick them in a cage and then the chicken,
they fuck each other.
Just do fake chicken fighting.
See I'm a gay chicken come out when the blonde wig and,
all right guys,
I lost Sean that
it's gotta be real chicken.
Can't believe it's gold guys real.
I came up with a guy who blows dust.
No,
his dad,
you named it dusty
roads and it's going to know that he exists and he's got a brother named Cody
Rhodes who just made the jump to being star dust,
which is the,
uh,
he's like the,
he's like another version of gold dust except up now they roll together so he's
gay too.
Now star dust is more like,
just like about the cosmos and like,
ah,
I just can't believe all the magical things.
Oh
yeah,
he's high.
Yeah.
So he's
stone the stone to the gills.
Oh,
that's so funny.
Except he's just,
ah,
you never know.
Do you think that it's possible to,
Tony could gave me to like pro wrestling.
Yes.
Oh,
I know for a fact,
dude.
I would know.
I knew the exact match.
Is the videos,
the moves,
the everything that would,
that would interest you or is he too much real?
There's some crazy submission moves that a no,
no,
no.
Dot.
Last.
That's the last thing you want to show me.
Don't that'll get me angry.
I'd be like,
that wouldn't work,
right.
No defense here.
You said hip escape.
He can get out of there.
Nothing drives me crazier than like a fake submission move in a movie.
That shit drives me nuts.
You know,
I stopped watching Dexter because fucking,
what's his name from third rock?
John Lithgow.
John Lithgo have this chicken of her naked choke in a bathtub.
And He,
and he killed her that way.
And I was like,
oh my God,
that's the worst fucking room naked choke I've ever seen.
That's so fake.
She's not even red.
I'm done.
And I shut it off.
I walked out of the room and discussed and I never watched another episode of
Dexter again.
Wow.
Yeah.
You can't show me a fake rear naked choke.
You fucks that.
That makes me angry.
That's like if you were watching a Jimi Hendrix bio pick,
uh,
you know,
a non bio pic,
but like,
uh,
you one of those movies where it's a fake,
like an actor plays Jimmy Hendrix.
I guess that's a biopic,
right?
Yeah.
And some do didn't know how to play guitar and he's like,
can around here own right.
And he'd be like,
no,
y'all got killing it.
You're not doing it at all.
You're not playing guitar.
That's what John Lithgow,
it's Shitty fucking Renee get choked did for me.
The only reason I think that you would maybe like it in the future is that you
like,
you know,
UFC so much in MMA and Jujitsu so much and Tony gets it together with a bunch of
people and watches it.
A lot of them watch it as a joke where Tony I think takes it a little bit too
serious.
Oh No,
we all watched it as a joke.
I can,
I'm not buying a joke.
I just see and recognize what's entertaining about it.
And I do like the ideology of stunning in arena of people.
Sometimes that happens.
It can happen.
You have to look at the reaction to that is the three hour like job interview
for you.
This is like your audition tape.
They should fucking hire you.
They should figure out how they can,
I need you to pull this up.
Where are you binge listen,
take the needle out of your ass and hire this guy.
You're crazy not to.
You should have seen the looks on these people's faces when Brock beat the
undertaker.
Nobody.
Yeah.
Thought it was going to happen.
Oh my God.
What did they do,
Tony?
Imagine if on Saturday the fuck is wrong with you and that nobody thought it was
going to happen.
It was amazing.
It was fake as fuck dude.
But nobody thought it was going to happen.
A lot of things are fake that nobody thought was going to happen.
Tony,
I'm sorry.
Imagine if that guy
who filled in for that Shit's getting around on Saturday and he took on
Dillashaw imagine if in the miracle he was able to somehow land a punch on
Dillashaw beat him.
The place would have been.
I mean,
well it's sort of weird cause that's Sacramento and that's Dillashaw his
hometown.
But I'm just saying like in a neutral field,
that would have been stunning and everybody would have known that they just
witnessed history
20 that would have been real.
Right.
No one can really tell the really,
really knocked out a professional athlete to guys who've trained to fight their
entire lives.
It's real.
Right,
right.
I understand you're,
you,
you're so crazy.
By the way,
this stuff is trying to sell insurance here.
No,
I know.
I understand where your concerns are,
but let me just show you the details of our policy.
You're a crazy person.
No,
I'm telling you why there's millions and millions of WWF and I'm telling you
why.
Maybe hunters Thompson was just a couple of decades off when he was predicting
the end of the world.
Those guys,
they mean it's not easy.
If,
for example,
Brock was furious when Vince told him that he wanted him to beat the undertaker
that day.
Like in real life.
Like okay,
Betty was,
and you were there to see it.
No,
but I talked to somebody who was,
oh,
I bet he was honest with you.
It's not like they lie all day.
Every day.
Tony,
Tony's going to talk to some people.
Let me tell you a little,
tell you what Brock was actually mad.
He was really mad.
He read the script and you just start doses.
Bullshit.
I'm not picking a fucking hundred taker of the,
some of the guys that work,
unlike the technical side for the UFC work for the WWE,
art,
Brock was crying.
That's what I heard was Brock went into the hospital with the undertaker,
cried so hard.
He dehydrated himself.
After that match.
They had to give them an IV to replenish.
His team thought he killed the undertaker.
From that.
Concussion is bad.
Bad.
It was real.
The concussions are real.
You can't buy that.
I don't even buy.
It was a real concussion.
I probably faked a concussion
then got JT on.
Don't take her to the hospital.
He's got up Bobo and even on the,
they don't feel real booboo folks.
If you don't take,
it's a real boob.
La,
show you the fucking band aid on it.
Are you doing it on my four year old boy?
It's like you're pitching something and four year olds.
So booboo,
booboo,
honey,
there's no,
because he's not even bleeding.
You don't need a bandaid.
Oh,
I want a bandaid.
Okay,
well Ben,
they make you feel better.
We'll get you a bandaid.
Did took the undertaker and put a bandaid on them.
Hey
Tony Hinchcliffe in a gold suit holding the script.
I can't believe it's our real poopooed jumping up and down circles and Vince
Mcmahon stand there shaking his head color of purple.
All fucking pent up with rage.
That's how I wrote it
down.
It's a booboo.
Look at the bandaid.
It's real.
It's a real bandaid.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you doubt it.
What else do you like?
That sucks.
Um,
let's see.
What else do I like?
It sucks.
Uh,
um,
I guess I play fantasy football.
I don't talk about that a lot.
Well,
fantasy football is at least based on fucking football,
right?
Which is a real game.
People are really trying and shit really happens,
but nobody knows what's going to happen in real sports.
Isn't that part of what makes it exciting?
You fucking Weirdo.
IBW eight Oh shit.
What's going to happen?
You don't know what's going to happen.
You predicted a writer.
No.
The writer knows what's going to happen.
Oh,
the writer knows it's not real.
It's like a play plays.
Musicals.
Now I've been the one that he's gay or than musicals.
How about that?
That doesn't make sense.
Sure it does.
It's dude's are hugging.
They get all sweaty.
They're laying on each other.
They're an and it's not real.
Okay.
I mean,
after musicals guys are banging.
I don't know if they're banging.
I don't go to those things.
I'm not in that world.
You've seen a musical,
right?
Yeah.
She had a bunch of musicals.
Not there's anything wrong with being gay,
by the way,
but musicals are gay.
They just are.
It really is.
Unless it's a humorous musical.
Yeah.
Even then it's even then someone
kisses ass.
Right.
That's someone else.
That's a Photoshop,
but isn't it?
Yeah.
That's not the real who is that guy is kissing me that that's a fake guy.
Probably one of you out there.
Just go look for it.
That's the thing about the Internet,
man.
Here's a photo of you out there somewhere.
Someone's Photoshop to Dick in your mouth or you kissing ass or you doing
something ridiculous and over our Mustang.
Why did he do that as a challenger?
Why did he do that while he pulled his pants down and made someone kisses ass on
TV?
Probably.
That sounds like something he would do,
but he did.
You know it.
Why are you pretending you didn't watch that one?
It spits back think it.
They think that was over like 1213 years ago.
Something like that.
You weren't there yet,
Huh?
No,
I,
I can't remember.
I don't believe it.
I think you're being mocked.
That may have been during that period where once you guys kissed his ass,
fuck your brother.
Back yard wrestling kind of gauge how many people in the audience though.
That's insane.
Plus it's been winning the Monday night cable wars for over 20 years.
Think about that for a second.
Every Monday night at wins,
every single month they pulled TNA though.
They pulled TNA from a,
from a spike.
TV expenses.
Competition.
What's the problem with TNA?
Everything's terrible.
They're just completely,
it's not even in the same,
that's what it should be.
Bribed,
but it's not.
It's not even in the same ballpark.
What is it?
Well,
they used to have like a lot of MMA guys would do it.
Like King Mo was in TNA and rampages and TNA.
There's not good.
No,
no.
That's wrong with it.
Bad writing,
bad everything.
Could you go over there?
Maybe ma'am,
I shouldn't.
No,
I don't want it.
You don't turn down the WWE TNA.
Listen,
you could be the fucking mogul.
What did they give you a piece of the action.
What is the DNA said?
Listen,
we heard you on the Joe Rogan podcast.
We'd like the way you think about wrestling.
I think this organization has still has some life and we're willing to,
uh,
willing to cut you in on this.
Give you 10% of the action.
I own 10% of TNA.
I'm pretty sure 10% of the TNA wouldn't even get me what I would have made with
the WWE.
You son of a bitch.
Yeah.
They just lost their TV deal.
They don't have a TV deal.
Yeah,
they're done.
Then it's maybe it'll get picked up by like lifetime.
Vince Mcmahon beat Ted Turner.
What does Ted Turner and CNN,
CNN,
TNT,
TBS heat through Ted Turner at open checks that he would,
he would just sign any wrestler back and uh,
they were having wars on Monday nights.
They'd go against each other.
Vince WWE on the USA network and t and t had nitro and Ted Turner said,
whatever we need to do to beat Vince Mcmahon,
I will write the check to whoever.
So they offered,
they bought hall Kogan they bought all these,
this,
he believes I was there.
I was in that room.
No,
I didn't say I was there and he was just willing to spend whatever it takes.
That sounds like a plot,
like a plot in lack of ways or two different,
no,
I'm taught,
this is where it's real.
Just parts real.
That's the problem.
You've cried wolf through this whole podcast.
I never said it was real nice about Santa Claus repeating that it's not real.
I'm agreeing with you and now you're trying to tell us that the boogie man is
real.
That's what you're doing
for wrestling.
So real.
I said,
it's going to write it.
How much did Ted Turner spend millions and millions to buy?
Good.
The guys that were already developed from the WWF,
he bought all their biggest guys haul Cogan,
a macho man.
Randy Savage,
you know,
much a man,
dusty Rhodes,
I'm a slim Jim Fan.
Right?
Snapping list.
Dusty Rhodes.
He bought them all.
And how did it do they ended up winning the wars for a bunch of weeks in a row.
They did.
Yeah.
I turned it for like a year in a row.
And uh,
but then Vince,
uh,
bought Mike Tyson and made him refer a match at Wrestlemania with Steve Austin
and Sean Michelson than it dominated.
The rest is history.
That's it.
One move.
Yup.
Okay.